Let's go next to where do we want to go
next? Because there's just such a plethora
of people wanting to get on. Why don't we
go to let's go to Zellar from Rhode Island.
Zayla from Rhode Island. You're on the air.
Hello, David. How are you today?
I'm doing well, thank you.
I must say, I love discord
for some reason on the phone line. I would
you would say something and I would hear it
10 seconds later. So this is much nicer.
That's beautiful. All right. So if we win
both the Senate seats in Georgia, which I hope we
do with seven or not. Yes. How likely is it that
there might be a Democrat defector in the Senate
that might cause a problem? So I know that, for
instance, Joe Manchin is still in the Senate in
West Virginia. Why is it that despite us getting
50 seats, that that's going to be an issue for us?
I agree, I mean, listen it when you think about
something like, you know, the public option
that Joe Biden wants, it's not even clear
every Democrat supports that. I don't know if
Joe Manchin supports that. So the 50/50 with
Comilla as the tiebreaker is the starting point.
But you are going to potentially have a lot of
trouble actually whipping all the votes that
that you would need to even get to the 50.
So I completely agree with you. Now, on the other
side of that, there may be some reason slightly,
marginally more reasonable Republicans that would
be willing to come over as well. But I think
you're completely right that just getting to 50 50
with Comilla as the theoretical tie breaking vote,
it doesn't really get big legislation, legislation
done. It's still going to be a big fight.
Yeah, and obviously the moderate Dems are
slaves to their districts, whoever elected
them, are there even any Republicans who
could be persuaded over for legislation
like that that could defect from their side?
It depends on the issue completely. You're not
going to get Susan Collins to come over and say
Medicare for. All right. But there are certainly
ways in which, you know, there are probably
funding related things or priorities or whatever,
where Joe Manchin, because of his West Virginia
electorate, might not be with the Democrats,
but Susan Collins, because of the Maine
electorate, might be with the Democrats. So there
are definitely examples. But you're not going to
pass like tax reform, Biden's tax reform proposal.
You're not going to get that because
of Republicans with Joe Manchin
not participating. That's not going to happen.
You're going to need every Democrat for that.
And how much of a problem of thorn in the
side do you think the filibuster might be
if we do get very close margins on legislation?
I think it will be a problem. I think that if
if Democrats do get 50 50 and Biden is in
a position to pass some major legislation,
I do think the issue of the filibuster will
come up. But on what issue? I don't yet know.
And what do you think so far with
the Supreme Court that we have now?
Yeah, and even previous to the death of
our gear, our big rather grb. Right, the.
Legislation. I mean, the case is
rather than past the Supreme Court.
I remember that there was the victory with
the anti-discrimination for trans people,
if I remember correctly, that happened not
too long ago. Do you see any cases or any
important decisions being made by the Supreme
Court that could be negative given the now very
cemented conservative majority on the court?
Absolutely. I wouldn't be able to say what
we first have to see what comes before
the court. But I'm very worried about
about the Supreme Court for sure.
Listen, I've got to run Zayla,
but I appreciate the call. I love that so many
people called in. I'm not able to take more calls
today, but we will take more calls soon.
And we will take a quick break and be back
with much more The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman Duchon.